[Applause]
love
the flow
[Music]
oh austin the progressive oasis of the
great state of texas
say defutting the fuzz looks like just
the ticket here now i recently set up
shop there for the latest installment of
change my mind if you missed that
segment you can click the card
or the link in the description down
below to check it out but even after we
found a sidewalk that wasn't entirely
soaked with bum piss
not too many people were eager to sit
down
your car mr sonata
[Music]
on the other hand some felt a little too
comfortable approaching some of our fans
right now i will not be annoyed by y'all
females man
says y'all
exactly you don't know me all right
let's just back up if i was john cena
i bet you you're if i was the reign to
rock
justin you're nobody wants to [ __ ] your
man you might want to get out of here
man leave me the [ __ ] alone man don't
touch me bro get out of here
leave me alone get out here leave the
women alone
you touch me i'ma crush you bro you're
gonna curse me now i know witchcraft
from
okay that's fine don't touch me bro well
i'm not gonna touch you but
you don't know witchcraft fool i
understand i'm gonna crush you and your
firstborn son you touch me
okay all right well i don't want that
number my firstborn son but you know if
you have to you have to do what you have
to do
just leave the women alone and go on
your merry way no i could do whatever i
wanted no you can't america
actually you can't that's assault i
didn't touch the lady okay
good so let's keep it that way but she's
uncomfortable no being pretty violent no
no
no no i'm out here doing the work of
jesus christ
trying to defend these goddamn men out
here for these sorry ass females out
here
jesus christ call a lot of women gold
digging suckers did he i didn't really
read about that and i didn't read about
that in march
you want to read the bible i got the
problem with me go ahead and read your
bible and do your witchcraft thanks man
is everyone uh everyone good
yeah you okay by the way just what we're
talking about you know
i saw the big wonder woman sign don't
forget the ladies which seem to have
been forgotten right now with the
looting and black lives matter and this
stuff going on
this is a perfect example what you just
saw of an anti-rape culture
i saw every man around step in make sure
that the women were safe we was he was
following them he was chasing them
and i didn't see a bunch of guys going
oh yeah secretly we're on board with the
rape i saw every guy get protective
and want to keep the women safe i
appreciate you guys doing that um
thank you and it's not virtue signaling
it's not white knighting it's just
making sure that women don't get hit
women don't get hurt women don't get
raped
i think we're all on board with that
that's what men instinctively want to do
so good to see the city's priorities
come to fruition
keep austin weird
and remember if you want these
conversations to continue please
consider joining up at
lottoworthcrowder.com mug club where you
get a wonderful hand-etched mug
an exclusive full-length daily show and
it helps us to go out and make the kind
of content that you see here
but on with the show word got to antifa
that i was in town and they decided to
make an appearance
[Music]
that i'm not going to is because this
narrative is dangerous and this
narrative got
garrett foster murdered do you want to
say that these people out here
saying black lives matter are domestic
terrorists you're putting lives at risk
so i will not talk to you
you know what you're doing david foster
was killed because he aimed an ak-47
point blank in a car
the guy was right no but the police
report
let's change the sign let's change the
sign we're going to change a sign
just for you we're going to change a
sign just for you about garrett foster
brother
let's change the sign if you'd like to
see the conversation on garrett foster
that could have happened
click the link in this video but now
back to boombox boy for some more
uh piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
oh no mommy's checks didn't clear for
those clutch lessons
now we were sitting down for a nice
conversation with our new friend molly
who
unbeknownst to angela just happens to be
biracial but
these guys seem to think that it's
dangerous to have conversations and they
continue to try and shut it down
online we'll be able to hear you yeah um
you said two years ago you left you were
more liberal
yeah what changed so i actually remember
the epiphany i had i was sitting on the
couch i don't want that product
placement oh yeah
so two years ago after numerous
conversations with my husband who's on
the offensive line
stop silencing black voices stop silence
voices stop silencing black voices
stop silencing black voices stop
silencing black voices
stop silencing black voices stop
silencing black voices
stop silencing black voices
[Music]
you stopped it worked sorry i know
there's a little tokenism there but i
hope you understand
i can't believe that worked no wait i i
totally can
it's a common ailment in which the
identity politic obsessed brain
experiences a neurotransmission short
circuit
and it is no non-laughing matter on with
molly
okay so you left yeah what was the
epiphany so two years ago sitting on the
couch with my husband and we
had multiple conversations we've been
together eight years oh wow yeah so
we've been married before anyway
two years ago after multiple
conversations i was sitting on my
section on the couch and my husband said
something
and he said this isn't hard to start
with the first amendment but this isn't
about
just altering the constitution it's
about long term if you start somewhere
where is it going to end
so that's what kicked it off then i
started thinking all right that's true
what other logical facts and things can
i
can i put together so then i started
researching so i realized the news never
talked about matter or numbers
right so then i started looking at my
own incredible slides like the fbi cdc
the u.s census and that's when i started
uncovering that the narrative doesn't
make sense
it doesn't make sense at all and do you
want me to touch on like black lives
matter or
sure you can touch today let me ask you
my question is this these people who
claim that they're obviously in line
with black lives matter that guy just
said that they've been there having his
back
um boy i i hate this is my real concern
and you tell me if you've seen this
black lives matter we have their charter
here and antifa since they're one of the
same
my concern is that it'll breed more
racism because you see this
behavior most black people are not on
board with this
but they unfortunately have a megaphone
to speak for them and i will tell you
i do see younger people having this
rebound effect
and that's what i was curious i wanted
to talk with you about because you're
here you're obviously you're
black biracial voice um and they show up
to silence us because they said we were
putting black lives at risk that really
scares me
i wonder what that's like living as a
black person right now who doesn't agree
and they speak for you
it's really
and the reason why i'm not on board with
like things like black lives matters is
because it's like why are we focusing on
like i'm gonna
i don't know
in fact actually when i was on the cdc i
was like okay what's the top killer for
white people it's just not even like the
the young age so i know it's number one
for like 15 to 34 homicides
right it's like 15 to 44 but yeah okay
yeah yeah so
i saw actually which seems weird to me
it's actually 14 i think we have them
right here this is the uh
yeah we have the department of justice
like 14 to 44 which 14 year olds are
committing murders are they ch
black chucky dolls in the top 10 right
yeah
it's number one killer for young people
but i think it's like number six like
overall top ten
right okay so then we go i was like okay
well surely if i go to like the white
hispanic
ethnicities it's going to be in the top
10 homicide it's not not even the top
time
even if you go to poor area so then it's
also like why why why why we're not
violent by nature we're not bad people
black people are not bad
and it goes down to socioeconomic things
around welfare and the family unit
that's what's so disturbing we're
talking about this with the black lives
matter chart a lot of people don't know
this you can go find on their website
you know disrupt the western prescribed
nuclear family so
not with that so when you when you
abolish the police
by the way i find it hilarious they also
want to abolish prisons like derek
shavin in prison right back out
like how do you keep police officers
accountable but destroying the western
prescribed nuclear family
that will do irreparable harm to not
only america at large but specifically
black communities that's something that
we need i mean i noticed a wedding ring
now have you been married for eight
years you got hollywood married for four
oh congratulations
thank you year five is when it kind of
settles in i've been married for eight
years now
oh [ __ ] i have an anniversary coming up
i just realized i forgot about it i just
realized um
yeah it is i think and this is what i
was trying to talk about
and we just sat down and spoke with that
black man who unfortunately i think we
made some headway
and he asked me why i wouldn't saddle up
and protest with him
but then he wouldn't just ask him to
stop drowning out it's like well you
want me to go and protest with you in
luke
and basically riot as you've seen in
austin but you won't
have this guy just stop silencing our
speech
so it is uh it is really concerning to
me that we're not looking at
all black lives exactly and uh these
people speak for the guy who's trying to
dress up like kick ass over here you
know that's where he's inspired right
you saw a kick-ass movie poster he's
like that's gonna look awesome yeah
i'm gonna ally the [ __ ] out of this vest
yeah
but yeah you're you're right and i think
because i was on the opposite side a
couple of years ago where i didn't want
to really think about it
and the logical steps and asked why um
it's really hard i understand like
the hard thinking but the part of its
pride like you don't admit that you're
wrong you've been
instilled all your life when you're a
minority especially in the black
community you're a victim you're the
victim you're a victim the government
owes something the government owes you
something
i'm not a victim yeah it doesn't seem
like it
uh i think the victims are these guys
out here who are wearing these get-ups
and
they'll never get to hear a point of
view like yours no and it's very
uncomfortable because then
you know when you're not white
um and you are for the things that we're
talking about like fixing the family
unit
taking talentability within community
focusing on the right things that they
make black lives
matter you're seeing
a traitor and it's like why does my skin
color my race have to determine
what party i'm so affiliated with yeah
no i understand yeah and it's
unfortunate that this is the kind of
behavior that's
been taking place in these protests and
it's branded black lives matter
it's really uncomfortable when people
assume just because you look a certain
way like how's that not racist
yeah well it's also really racist to
look at those statistics and assume that
it's just because of color of skin
and not understand that it's because of
family units it's because of the
breakdown not asking the right questions
why why why i think my community were to
keep asking
why are we like this what has happened
in our past
like an honest conversation we would
start to uncover i think it
in my opinion it goes down to the family
unit thing that's where it starts
in our community well statistically it's
undeniable and you know what
here's something that i think that you
and i we talk about privilege take for
granted
first off the biggest privilege i've
ever had is i have a mother and a father
who love me
um but we do both enjoy a privilege and
that i just spoke with a man who's a
black lives matter activist
who believes in abolishing the police
yeah i got to speak with him and hear
his point of view and he heard mine
you'll get to speak with people like
that here these people these antifa
protesters
will never have the privilege of hearing
a different point of view they'll never
have they want to [ __ ] about education
they'll never have the privilege of
actually educating themselves to be all
or nothing you know why can't we be in
the middle
i know all right well thank you i didn't
catch your name my name's molly
molly yeah i can shake your hands thank
you molly i appreciate you coming out
stay safe they might not be happy with
you so
thank you thank you so much
yeah let's move along
that's fine let's let's go a long path
around
[Music]
when the black girl leaves he starts his
motorcycle
up it works like a charm right on cue
from clutch prick
so what do you think how would you deal
with these kinds of
mob tactics especially in a time when
people are unfortunately
increasingly resorting to violence let
me know in the comments below
have a discussion uh as you enjoy
antifa's remaining tolerance on display
for all to see
and we'll be there we do not entertain
people who say dave foster was a
terrorist
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
did you guys love inbreeding let's go
bring your [ __ ] capitalist [ __ ]
elsewhere
[Music]
what do you want what do you want put a
mask on [ __ ] people are dying no
need to put masks on all they got
all you know what do you want bro huh
what do you want
just be your friend man really then you
should wear them
six feet away if you're gonna try to be
my friend bro hey these
[ __ ] aren't wearing masks is that not
a problem this fat
is going to give me pelvis is that not a
problem of course it's not because i'm
scary
take those glasses off
y'all are the reason people are laughing
at this country
how hard is it to wear a mask for other
people
y'all are the reason people hate the usa
you're the reason we're the most
civilized nation
that doesn't have universal health care
how many people have to die
herman cain already died he died an
avoidable death to own the lives
good on him i hope you all do the same
you're ridiculous how you want to argue
with scientists and doctors
go around and find out that's my message
for all of you
suckers they can't just wear a mask have
a nice day
hey there youtube viewer if you like
this installment of changed my mind
click on one of these other installments
playing in a box that's the only way you
can find it because if you search it it
may not show up because it's
controversial and youtube wants to um
discourage that the controversy
to change my mind playing by the rules
we just don't know what they are
subscribe and hit notifications